In today's video we're gonna see if we can make a magnetic sand by crushing up powerful magnets in a blender
*intro music*
A while ago, I saw a video with a bunch of powerful magnets asking 'will they blend in a powerful blender?'
They had a string of those little neodymium magnets that look like bb's and they lowered it down into the blender and
Blended it into powder. It was pretty cool
And we saw a lot of sparks in that video
But I was kind of disappointed that they didn't show anything about what was left
So we're gonna try blending up some magnets see if we can replicate that same effect
And then we want to take a look at that stuff. Here's the basic idea:
We've got a bunch of powerful neodymium
Magnets, and we're going to try and blend those up into a fine powder and then see what that powders like
Is it still magnetic? Will it hold itself into whatever shape we put it into can we use it to make magnetic slime?
So we're gonna try breaking up and blending up a bunch of these types of magnets and see what's left
I'm really hoping that the blender holds up as well as it's supposed to because these things getting hit by the blades at high speeds
Hopefully we don't have it shatter on us
most of these silvery magnets I have here the really strong ones are what are called neodymium magnets and
They are largely comprised of neodymium. That's an atomic element They also have iron and boron in them an interesting thing about these though is they actually can be fairly brittle now...
I don't know if this will break right now, but sometimes these magnets are powerful enough that just pulling themselves together
They can actually break on impact. So I'm gonna see if I can get that to happen
Shatter perfectly magnet absolutely shattered on contact
I wasn't sure if it was going to but it did and that's just because these magnets pull on each other so hard
Slams together with a lot of surface on surface contact the whole thing is just taking a lot of impact
It would have exploded
Except all of those pieces are still being attracted down to the magnet
So it doesn't have enough force to go anywhere as a first test to see if this will sort of powder eyes
Let's just take this over to our handle and take a hammer to it and see what that does
After going at it with a hammer this is what is left of one of these magnet squares
So we've got the same amount of material here
Clearly changed form. So it does kind of feel like sand and you can see that it's holding itself together
So is it still magnetic? I'm gonna have to say it's still somewhat magnetic because I can pull it apart easily
But like it doesn't lose pieces. There's not sand falling off of it. I can just smush it easily
I can pull it apart easily see how it compares in terms of magnetic strength. I've got a steel plate here
This magnet on its edge still strong enough to lift up the plate
If it would stay centered there we go in comparison our
magnet sand
Not even strong enough to hold itself to the plate. Even if we flat it out. So it's more like the original shape. Oh
You know what that actually helped
It's definitely still weak
but it now can hold itself up and that's probably just it has more surface area of
The sand that's actually in contact with the plate. So we have an interesting proof of concept
I think the blender is going to do a better job than the hammer and anvil of crushing this stuff into an even
Sand like powder. So we're gonna try that now and boy, is it gonna be loud?
I'm gonna start off with some of these fairly small magnets
It seems like the better way to go and take magnets in the top this way when I remove these at the top
Those ones should fall down into the spinning blender blades
Well, it blended them that does not look like it was really good for our blades
That's kind of chewed up in there
it also
Stopped blending after just a few seconds and I think that the magnets are being attracted to the base just enough that it's holding down
Underneath the blades and so it's just spinning and not much is happening. So we're just gonna have to add more magnets into it
Well, we've got quite a bit of blended magnets here
But it's actually in larger pieces than when we hit it with the hammer
It just ends up getting stuck down to the bottom and I think it's just too attracted to parts of the bottom of the blender
and
It's not really getting pulled up by any air current created by those blades
So we're gonna keep trying to blend this up even more and see what we get out of it
Like this, this is how we're really getting somewhere we're getting it small and blended up
I'm just gonna keep doing this a few more times and see how blended this can get
Looking pretty good liking this stuff
so I've now run this through the blender five times or so and well, it's not like
100% perfectly smooth it's doing pretty well. Just feel like there's one little chunk right here
So this is what I was hoping to see
After the video of the magnets being blended up. Yes, it blends up the magnets pretty well, but I wanted to see what's left
So here we've got a larger quantity of this stuff
We smashed them up with a hammer and now we smashed it up with a blender and this is what we've got
Like it's not falling apart like a blob of sand would and this is completely dry. It's just holding itself together
So it does have some magnetic attraction to itself. Let's try our steel plate test again
Try and give it a nice flat surface that helped bond a little bit more last time I think
There we go enough attraction to hold it upside down
See how the attraction is to an actual magnet though
so the powderized magnet is attracted to the magnet so it's still
Ferromagnetic, it still can be attracted by a printed magnet but it itself has lost a lot of its magnetic power
Magnets can lose their magnetism from heavy impact and of course when you break them up
So small
The polarity is not going to be all uniform and just facing north and south the way they are when they're a solid piece
Even if each of these tiny little pieces still holds its own magnetic charge, they're now all jumbled up and pointing in different directions
So it's not acting as a single magnet and the magnetic fields can actually interfere with each other or cancel each other out to some
Degree, so for this to have the same amount of magnetic power as the whole magnets would have been very unexpected
Anyway earlier I said we might try this
I'm going to mix up a batch of slime and see if we can mix this
Magnet powder into this line and make a little bit of magnetic slime like that
All right, we've got ourselves a little batch of clear slime here see if we can't mix in some of our magnet powder
It's interesting because of how much the magnets and kind of likes to stick to itself
It's having a very hard time mixing up inside the slime because it doesn't like to separate out much
We've got some
Attraction to our very powerful magnet here
Looks like we kind of just have a blob of the sand
Surrounded by the slime. It's it's not very evenly mixed in
Of course the magnet is very attracted to the steel plate underneath it it is attracted to it
But I think it's just pulling all of the magnet stuff through that. Yep. There we go
This is like how to remove your magnets and from your slime rather than making magnetic slime
Here's our original
Magnetic putty we made with some magnetite powder compare how that gets attracted to the magnet here. It's not pulling anything out
It's just pulling all of it together. I
Could watch that all day that is like the coolest thing that you can deal with magnets
I think so making our magnets and our DIY magnets and into a magnetic slime
It doesn't work as well as when we use the artificially created magnetite this stuff doesn't mix into the slime very well at all
So I got to say it's not as effective
But it's kind of cool to watch it get drawn over by a magnet and you can just pull some of the magnet dust
Right out of it. One more thing. I wanted to try. I wanted to see what happens
If we heat this stuff up, will it just turn into?
Metallics and will lose all of its ability to hold itself together
All right little torch
See what you can do
A lot of cool sparks coming off of that. I like that
Glowing orange here at the top that went really quickly
It's holding itself together quite a bit less
Any more cohesive once it cools down a bit see this is just not the same
There's before we heated it up stays together in this pile. And even if we try and separate it out into separate little
Sanded. It just doesn't do it now that we've heated it up
Nothing doesn't hold together even a little bit
Just the dust that was sparking a lot as I smashed it. So I'm gonna try heating it up again
And then while it's still hot, I'm gonna hit it with the hammer
It's now flatter and it's any contact with this steel plate
So it's not heating up as evenly or as easily as it was before you
Know what? I'm just gonna move on up to the big boy torch. Ah
That was great, that was a cool little shower sparks. That's a cool shower of sparks too. Holy cow that
Is so cool
Three two one
This is a cool little tool that lets you actually see magnetic fields, it's pretty neat
It's got some magnetic powder in this sheet and it gets attracted around and when you bring a magnet
Into the presence of it you can actually watch its magnetic field show up
I bring a much stronger magnet near it the effect is accentuated quite a bit
Very powerful magnetic field then when we compare that to our
Magnetics and it shows up a little bit very disjointed. It's not uniform at all
Even if it still has its magnetism it's not facing all one direction. So it's not uniform. It doesn't create one
Magnetic field that's just creating thousands of tiny magnetic fields that are often interfering with each other
guys, that's not all we've always got more for you to see this box up at the top is gonna take you directly to our
Last video you should go check that out
The other box shows you what YouTube thinks you can be watching next. Ok, this bomb here in the middle
You'll be subscribed to the channel. That way you're never gonna miss out on a cool video
Don't forget to ring that Bell and we'll soon the next one talk to them